okay should we do the thing that's right
for our users or should we do the thing
that makes us money so that our business
stays afloat
[Music]
it's Wednesday
I'm just making some lunch in the middle
of making spam Musubi we used to be
really bad at making soupy actually
and then our friend taught us how to
make it right yes and he was like it's
not hard to make I don't know why we had
such a hard time I think it's because we
didn't know to buy this thing
and then we just made a huge difference
that did and then the order of
operations is also kind of important too
but
I just
fried up some spam so I just like cooked
it on both sides with oil and then I
added soy sauce and meeting for salty
sweet savoriness
and then I'm about to start assembling
the first thing you do is you get
naughty and then you put the thing on
top
on top fill it with a layer of rice rice
and then you use this thing and then you
push it down
and then it makes this layer nice and
flat inside
in goes
the spam and then more rice
I'm gonna go
you destroy and then what you actually
do is you leave it here
this
and a little this make it actually
naughty which also means glue
and like that
uh
we've been eating noodles like every day
for lunch
which was great but I'm a little sick of
noodles right now which I didn't think
was possible but I am
to even go on between rice and bread and
salad for lunch all right wow I'm tired
I just finished filming a video about
technical interviews and uh it went well
I kind of had fun with it because it's
kind of a dry topic and
I figured what I'll make fun wish I did
have fun but now I'm just
but as a reward for myself I'm going to
build this dog bed that I got from
Amazon for Kona because kona's dog bed
look
oh
it's falling apart and I wanted to see
if this new type of bed that I bought is
like a good one I did get this one also
because Jarvis has the same dog bed for
his new dog by the way he has a puppy
he's so cute but anyways it's the same
bed and I was gonna build it and see if
Connor likes it this thing is actually
really light for having an entire pet
bed in here
I think it's just supposed to inflate
oh here's what the bed looks like
Kona come on go to bed
go to bed
go
yes good boy
good boy go to bed oh it's okay it's
okay oh he's like I'm on my old bed are
you just waiting to steal it from him
you are aren't you I'm gonna try it one
more time
yes good boy good boy good boy there you
go this might be too small for you hi
nope
I think it looks nice but it might be a
little too small for Conan he likes very
roomy beds really do you want to try
getting in here oh I think this is yours
this is you sized look at how much more
natural Ellie looks in this bed
that's an Ellie sized bed oh good girl
he's so cute good morning happy Friday
I've got a lot of work to finish up
today but I did also just get a monitor
I'm doing a video with LG like in a few
uh weeks and they wanted me to review
the monitor so I got it today I was
gonna
yes hello so yeah I'm gonna set it up
but
bought some new accessories from my desk
specifically uh I bought Wheels like
rolling casters for these because the
other day I set up my desk with my
camera behind it and I was like wouldn't
this be easier if I had wheels on it so
I could just wheel my desk around and
then I also got like one of these things
that you can pop into one of the whole
sockets so that becomes a charging port
because more often than not I'm like I
just need an outlet and a charger and I
don't have any more in my room ones
because they're all charging like this
kind of stuff and so I'm gonna set that
all up I think it's gonna be
not a trivial amount of work but I'm not
quite ready to get started in my day yet
so let's procrastinate together
[Music]
my room right now is unbelievably messy
like
ah check it out
so messy hey but the monitor's up thing
about cord management cleaning I feel
like it has to get Messier before it can
get cleaner
[Music]
it's done here is my final setup dude
I'm really happy with this I'm gonna
make a video about the review for this
once I use it a little bit more so if
you're not subscribed please do so but
I'm going to try using it now Tabby
Tuesday everybody oh I just finished
lunch and man it's cold in San Diego
that's why I'm like fully stubborn I'm
actually still very cold my hands are
freezing but uh I
uh I'm gonna get a haircut today because
I am sick of my own hair I've just been
having it tied up this whole time and
it's not even that long it's just like
it's at the really awkward length
we're like it's like okay is it gonna
grow out longer or is it just gonna like
sit awkwardly on my shoulders the last
time I cut this was like when was the
last time I cut this I think I cut it in
April last time and I'm gonna go get a
haircut for the first time in two years
because every time I've cut my hair
since covid started I just cut it myself
because I was never cutting it that
short and it was easy to because I
didn't have to like
be able to see what was going on but I'm
gonna go get my hair cut probably not
gonna Vlog very much there because
vlogging in public
scary very scary but I will show you
what it looks like afterwards
I did a thing and moved my desk into my
bay window area because I got these
rolling casters that I could put I think
I showed it on my previous Vlog
um but I can move my desk anywhere and I
have this cute little seat that Ellie
usually loves sitting on so I moved it
over here and now Ellie
gets to sit right next to me slash I get
to sit right next to her while I work
which is great hello and happy Wednesday
I just finished filming a video about
this very monitor I thought I'd show you
what my YouTube setup looks like
actually alright so this is basically
what my setup looks like pretty dang
often if I have my computer in the back
then I'll have one light here because I
get a lot of light from that window so I
try to kind of like bounce this light on
the other side of my face I've got a
microphone which is connected to my
voice recorder thingy and then I've got
my camera and a tripod and the camera
has a battery that connects straight
into the wall and Ally Ellie is an
important part of this whole equation
she is my production assistant that only
ever sleeps man I saw did I had a really
good therapy session yesterday and I was
talking to my therapist and we ended up
talking about like I don't know just
feeling kind of very creatively stuck
specifically it's just like this whole
tension between like okay do what you
love but also make it valuable for other
people so that they will watch it or pay
money for it which is very capitalistic
but I don't know I feel like that's just
like a attention that I feel frequently
even when I was in tech it's just like
okay should we do the thing that's right
for our users and our and our customers
and our employees or should we do the
thing that makes this money so that our
business stays afloat to employ all of
those people so my therapist gave me
some good advice where she was just like
you know I think you're probably trying
to fight something right now and maybe
just see what happens when you let go
which I don't know what it is that I'm
holding on to or what I'm fighting
because it's very abstract but
trying to let that flow through me today
because I think
you know it's like it's like reading a
fortune cookie or an astrology like
thing where it's like maybe it doesn't
make sense concretely but if you take
those words to Heart then it can change
how you view your life it can change
your actions and you know this might as
well keep yourself open to the
opportunity and the possibility because
you never know what happens or what
could happen
happy Saturday everybody
about to do some Home Improvement
because we haven't had the chance to do
that also we thought our bathroom was
leaking so we cut a hole up there to see
what the situation was luckily it wasn't
leaking which we only would have known
if we cut up that drywall
so now I gotta patch it which I actually
really like patching drywall once it
gets to the mudding part software
engineer takes on post projects
because she's older now
and she's almost 30 so she
should know how to do it like this
probably
holy heck it worked basically here's the
paper here's the hole so now I just
gotta plug it up
I mean
I mean it fits
it's a little too big yeah let's let's
do it let's do it
Welcome to our garage where we have too
much
around everywhere but we do have tools
we don't have
[Music]
apparently what I'm supposed to do
this is the part that's supposed to be
very very therapeutic and if it works it
will be incredibly therapeutic
[Music]
I'm good at this if this works out I
will put drywalling on my anyway I think
drywalling really is very similar to
just like playing with Play-Doh sort of
thing
oh my God
I am so good at this
I did this right right
foreign
[Music]
I did it you did it was it really easy
it was so much easier than any
drywalling I've ever done but look it's
packed thank you for being here with me
with DIY with muko this is a success
I'm pretty freaking happy about it
drywalling house projects not that scary
see you later
oh happy
Monday everybody oh the Sun's shining
through for once oh now it's gone that
was so fast
happy Monday everybody I just took a
little 30 minute nap
after lunch
because I was tired yesterday I just
drank like so much coffee that I didn't
get very restful sleep
last night so I took a little nap before
I started on my afternoon work but I
made some tea too by the way check out
this teapot that I got it's from Quinto
um my mom and dad got it for me for my
birthday and it's just like
it's one of those beautifully elegant
products that just makes your life
better and I'm so glad to finally have a
new teapot because I'm using the same
one forever I thought I'd actually take
some time to figure out what's inside
here this is the sakurako box and they
are the sponsor of today's video so
sakuroko is a monthly subscription box
that includes 20 different snacks treats
sweets and tea pairings that get
delivered right to your door every month
I'm really excited to try this one
because sakuroko is a Japanese based
company and so all their stuff comes
from Japan they're all artisanal and I
feel like
just gonna make a really good tea
pairing so let's look at what's inside
this is actually the November 2021 box
so if you see anything in here that you
want then make sure to order by the end
of this month October so that you'll get
it in time for the November box wow this
is so pretty this is so Japanese
postcard it's beautiful though
then it comes with a little guidebook
which is in Japanese book form because
it goes from this side to this side the
theme is Autumn and Kyushu so I'm
expecting lots of like potato related
things in here which yes
this is like one of my actually favorite
snacks of all time this is this thing is
it I freaking love this snack we got
some pie we got some Manju we got some
oh you're good and really big smacks
like this in here as well this one a
potato
[Music]
this is actually one of my favorite
parts of sakurako I got a box
um like a couple of months ago and they
all come with like one really nice like
Japanese wear which sometimes it's
really hard to find stuff like this in
the store or Amazon or online and stuff
so it's really nice that this kind of
stuff comes with the sakurako Box
actually has a monthly plan and several
prepaid plans so the plan starts at
32.50 for box charging you every 12
months they also have a limited
promotion this month and so if you use
the code sake2021 to sign up you'll get
a free Japanese sake glassware thing uh
according to the plan that you choose
all of these snacks in here are
incredibly Japanese and I've actually
never seen any of these before like I've
never seen them stock stuff like this at
the Japanese Supermarket or really any
Market in America or probably Japan
rather so make sure to check out the
link in the description box down below
to get your very own sakurako box now
comes the hard part which one do I
choose
bring this one up
oh
dude
um
more
um
oh [ __ ]
that's really good come on with the
castle under the moon Chestnut Manju
smooth blend of azuki sweet beans and
chestnuts
cycle
psycho I gotta say I do really benefit
from like
of all Asian things being Japanese I
think a lot of people just like Japan
and so companies like this exist and I
know that like I feel very lucky that I
get to like
have these kinds of services near me
where like I can just get snacks
delivered to my door that are Japanese
even without having to go to Japan
because man I miss Japan I still haven't
been since covet started
and I feel like eating Japanese food
touches some of like the deepest depths
of my soul so I definitely benefit from
y'all's obsession with Japan
those
services
foreign
[Music]